نتحدث بدون ادنى شكل على حدث الاستثنائي
نتحدث عن فشل الذريع ايضا في اجهزه الامن
الاسرائيليه ان كان على صعيد الرب وان كان
على صعيد التعامل وكذلك ايضا على صعيد
الاستخبارات وهذا بدون ادفك ايضا يعني
سيفكر الان لدى الجيش الاسرائيلي لدى
اجهزه الامن الاسرائيليه الحكومه
الاسرائيليه التي يجب ان تعطي الكثير من
الاجابات على هذا الاخفاق الامني
التسريبات الاوليه بدون اي مشاكل يعني
مسؤول عنها ايه الرقابه العسكريه
الاسرائيليه هنالك تجديد فقط التصحيح انه
كونه امنيا واظن ان هذا فقط يعني يدل على
هول المفاجاه
[موسيقى]
سابق كانت
الحوادث القليله التي تمت على الحدود
المصريه مع فلسطين المحتله لها طابع اقرب
الى السياسي او على خلفيه يعني ممارسات
اسرائيليه ضد
الفلسطينيين
وبالتالي تولد غيظا لدى عدد من الجنود
المصريين مثلما حدث من قبل في حادثه
سليمان خاطر في ثمانيات قرن الماضي
الحدود المصريه السعوديه هي هادئه منذ
سنوات واخر مره شهدت محاوله تسلل وقتل احد
المتسللين او المهربين قبل نحو عام ونصف